- Guten Tag.
- Ich finde es ja auch kalt.
Aber übertreiben Sie nicht ein bisschen?
- Übertreiben? Ich kann es nicht verstehen,
wie man diese lange Kälte aushalten kann.
- Man gewöhnt sich an das Klima.
- Ich hoffe!
- Woher kommen Sie?
- Ich komme aus Syrien.
- Da ist es natürlich meistens wärmer.
- Nur wärmer?
Manchmal ist es richtig heiß.
Kennen wir uns?
- Hm.
- Ähm … Wie kann ich Ihnen denn helfen?
- Ich möchte vielleicht ein gebrauchtes
Fahrrad kaufen und mich informieren.
- Das heißt, Sie haben noch keins?
- Genau. Aber meine Tochter Selma.
Sie hat ein Fahrrad.
Sie fährt damit zur Arbeit
und das ist günstiger als eine
Monatskarte für die Straßenbahn.
- Das verstehe ich. Ich zeig' Ihnen mal
unsere gebrauchten Räder, ja?
- Vielen Dank.